last Friday there were more than 200
small earthquakes here in Southern
California and they called it an
earthquake swarm and it got some media
attention there yeah and yeah and
seismologists some seismologists think
this could be a sign that a major
earthquake could hit any day now that's
just what they're saying yeah the next
one could be the big one yeah okay
that's so that's Tony that's one of our
cameramen Tony why is that funny yeah
the big one that's right Tony we're
talking about a major earthquake hey
Conan do you think you could handle the
big one well honestly I don't know I
mean I've lived in California for
several years so I've experienced plenty
of small and medium ones yeah I bet you
have how long do you think the big one
will be well I'm no expert but some say
the shaking could last up to a minute
well that's pretty long do you think the
big one would be hard hard to endure
oh yeah sure natural disasters can be
very hard on everyone yeah yeah very
hard
yeah there's no denying it Tony the big
one will be long but hard yeah yeah yeah
and do you think the big one will make a
big mess when it comes
it it probably will yeah I mean there
will be debris and rubble everywhere I
mean Tony this is serious the big one is
going to be long it's gonna be hard it's
going to run deep and it's gonna make a
huge mess when it comes the preceding
segment brought to you by the double
entendre Council of America additional
funding provided by ting Wallace rods
and poker's and Sal most hidden salami
the California pie Players Union : I'd
weasel Conservation Society Mulroney's
baloney ponies genitals that's right
just genitals in general dicks long
butts and Peter's LLP in-n-out burger
[Applause]
you